Taylor Swift Travis Kelsey have changed
the NFL's business is there a message in
that yes of course there is which is
that everybody on Earth underestimates
pop culture what happened with Taylor
and Kelsey is they're cross-pollinating
their platform so if you're a mechanic
in Detroit like I said in this post
you're not thinking about hitting up the
Thai restaurant down the street to do a
piece of social media content yeah
that's the kind of left field post that
will get people's attention what if
you're lucky enough to have an employee
that's first name is Travis and another
one that's first name is Taylor you can
easily use the micro moment of the
infatuation of our society to do
something clever and silly what people
don't realize is that little clever
video on Instagram that only got 90
views one of those 90 views is someone
who's actually considering to hire an
attorney and they actually like the fact
that you were a little silly and you
made them feel more comfortable to reach
out to you to work with your Law Firm or
your dentist's place people are very
linear they don't realize how big pop
culture is and how they can factor into
their boring business